frente al avance de las obras del
gasoducto eeuu aceptó lo evidente no
podrá impedir la construcción del nord
stream 2 entre rusia y alemania-
washington abandonó las sanciones
impuestas las empresas participantes en
2019 y llegó a un acuerdo con ver la
sesión ahora es poco probable que las
sanciones impidan que se materializa el
caso de un prisión
esta administración ha juzgado que es
contrario a nuestros intereses me anima
a perjudicar la relación bilateral de
aliados que tenemos con alemania
sin embargo la casa blanca persiste en
sus críticas al gasoducto basadas en que
rusia pueda utilizar la dependencia
energética de europa como un arma de
influencia de hecho el gas ruso ya
representa un 40% del consumido en
europa el north stream 2 desarrollado al
98% debe conectar directamente rusia y
alemania- los estadounidenses temen que
rusia deje de usar el gasoducto que pasa
por ucrania y que reporta 7000 millones
de euros anuales aquí es para atenuar el
poder ruso el acuerdo con berlín
estipula la posible aplicación de
sanciones a moscú en su visita a
washington de la semana pasada
angela merkel lo dejó claro también
actuaremos decididamente si rusia no
respeta el derecho de tránsito en
ucrania lo que significa que para mí el
nord stream 2 es un proyecto adicional y
no un reemplazo del proyecto que pasa
por ucrania lo contrario comportaría
fuertes tensiones pero kiev de la mano
de polonia critica el acuerdo entre eeuu
y alemania un tema que según el
ejecutivo de ucrania estará en la agenda
de la cita entre joe biden y su
ucraniano wladimir selenski en
washington el 30 de agosto